here's actual human evidence of what
happens if you were to eat mcdonald's
for 30 days straight huge thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
what would happen if i ate nothing but
mcdonald's for 30 days straight would i
suddenly be on the fast track to
becoming an obese american well it
really depends on how much food you're
consuming if you're going to be
consuming more calories than your basal
metabolic rate you will be putting on
weight america has now become the
fattest nation in the world nearly 100
million americans are today either
overweight or obese and the way that
they do that classification is through
the bmi system and i know the bmi system
has a lot of room not necessarily for
improvement but for inaccuracy even but
it's still an accurate representation of
risk not for everybody because this is a
general usage of bmi as opposed to
individual usage because if i see
someone who's very muscular and has a
high bmi i know that they're not
overweight but in general as a general
rule it's still good to look at it for
population metrics when i was growing up
my mother cooked dinner every single day
and we never ate out sitting down for
dinners has been linked to lower rates
of obesity but it's not a causal
relationship we don't know if that's
exactly what's causing people to lose
weight or is it because they're more
likely to be affluent and have secure
meals therefore have money to spend on
healthy foods there's a lot of variables
here that aren't controlled for which is
why we can't say it's a causation it's
just a correlation two things happening
at the same time
more bare hair obesity is now second
only to smoking as a major cause of
preventable death in america yet each
day
one in four americans visits a fast food
restaurant i imagine that number's even
higher today look at ryan trahan video
he's in mcdonald's every day and it's
not his fault he has five dollars to
spend on food he's gonna go to the
cheapest food mcdonald's alone operates
more than 30 000 joints in over 100
countries on six continents and feeds
more than 46 million people worldwide
every day it's interesting because
malnutrition before and still in some
parts of the world was due to not having
enough food food insecurity and now in
many developed nations you're having
malnutrition being as a result of excess
food or not the right food in excess are
the food companies solely to blame for
this epidemic
where does personal responsibility stop
and corporate responsibility begin to me
that's a false dichotomy is it personal
decision or is it corporate
responsibility it's both the company has
to care about its user or its eater and
the person has to care about their own
health and be educated about their
health i knew if i was going to do this
i would need some serious medical
supervision so i enlisted the help of
not one but three doctors a cardiologist
a gastroenterologist and a general
practitioner the general practitioner
should be the quarterback in the
situation it's what i do if the family
doctor is sending him to a specialist
it's to consult that specialist get some
kind of explanation for something that's
very complex that's occurring now if a
patient has diarrhea gerd dyspepsia not
every one of those patients needs a
gastroenterologist it's very important
that we understand that primary care
doctors are not referrologists now the
gastroenterologist here will probably be
tracking and making sure that he's not
having any kind of gi upset i think that
doctor is probably going to offer the
least value in this situation and the
cardiologist can offer some preventive
statistics about high cholesterol high
saturated fat intake but the primary
care doctor could do the exact same
thing usually without any of the
complicated lingo and at a much more
reasonable price point your general
health is outstanding your kidney
function your liver function they were
all perfect your blood level's fine your
iron level is good as well i expect to
see an increase in your triglycerides
because that will can be affected during
87 now and i think that will change what
you could also see is elevations and
liver enzymes because what you can have
happen is a fatty liver disease where
you actually have fatty deposits into
the liver which cause liver inflammation
as a result you have elevations in that
your ast and alt which are markers of
what we call liver function but it's
really liver inflammation i also went to
a fancy new york wellness center to meet
a registered dietitian who would help
track my progress is this nutritionist
and dietitian going to help him eat
unhealthy what are they going to track
your calorie needs are going to be
averaging about 2500 calories a day as
far as fat goes for 2500 calories you're
going to want about 80 grams of total
fat in a day the saturated fat which is
a component of total fat you want to
have less than 25 grams a day probably
even lower if you don't want your
cholesterol going up don't try to
overindulge too much
good luck morgan thank you
[Music]
i will only supersize it if they ask me
i can only eat things that are for sale
over the counter at mcdonald's water
included if mcdonald's doesn't sell it i
can't eat it i have to have everything
on the menu at least once over the next
30 days and i have to have three squares
a day breakfast lunch and dinner but you
can also choose the types of foods
you're eating even in mcdonald's and
make them healthy they do serve salads
yeah could i get the uh
double quarter pounder with cheese meal
i think i'm gonna have to go super sized
look at that
look at that coke but then what was the
purpose of going to the nutritionist and
dietitian who told me you shouldn't need
over 2 500 calories that meal alone is
probably 2 000 calories see now's the
time of the meal when you start getting
the mixed stomach ache you start getting
the mctummy right now i got i got some
mcgas that's rocking are you sweating
there my arms i feel like i got some mc
sweats going he's so corny it's painful
watching it back to the movie in just a
second but first i want to thank
hellofresh for sponsoring this video it
should not come as a surprise that as a
doctor i don't recommend eating only
fast food for 30 straight days
fortunately there are healthier options
for everyday dining like hellofresh if
you watched any of my cooking videos
before you know i'm not exactly an iron
chef which is why i like hellofresh
whose recipes come with easy to follow
instructions and all the ingredients i
need saving me time on shopping and
prepping my meals as well as less waste
they deliver the freshest meat fish
produce that goes from the farm right to
my door in under a week and i could
really taste that difference i'm talking
mexicali black bean soup spinach caprese
salad nacho mac and cheese delicious
they also make it easy for me to
increase the size of my oil which allows
me to feed a whole group or enjoy some
leftovers throughout the week there are
all sorts of options for different diets
like vegetarian pescetarian and more
which makes it so easy to stick to your
goals go to hellofresh.com and use promo
code drmik16 remember doctor is spelled
out and it's all in caps for 16 free
meals across seven boxes and three free
gifts all right let's get back to the
movie i don't feel good today not that i
feel sick
but um i just feel really depressed
you're not gonna get depressed on
feeding mcdonald's that's not what i'm
trying to say but if you don't get your
nutrients you will experience mood
changes and instability you're exerting
a lot of willpower to only eat the same
food that you're sick of that you don't
like that you know is unhealthy this is
taking significant a mental toll on you
so no this isn't a regular day in your
everyday life i really noticed i'll eat
some and just a little while later i'll
be hungry again and i want more you're
getting such a strong insulin spike
glycemic index on that food is probably
so high you instantly want to refill and
replenish that high that you got which
is basically a dopamine hit each time
you eat one of those mcdonald's meals
and because they're primarily made of
quick digestible carbs the fries the
white bun you do get hungry real quick
it's hard for me to watch him go through
this i worry about his health he's
exhausted by the end of the day me too
and i don't even eat mcdonald's every
day and now he gets all jacked up on
sugar and caffeine and then he crashes
and then when we do have sex i gotta
tell ya he's not quite as energetic as
he used to be well yeah he's crashing
hard so he's gonna have less drive less
circulation less energy i think the
saturated fats are starting to impede
the blood flow to his penis and he's
having a hard time you know getting it
up my body
officially hates me
all the vitamins that you see here
vitamin e thiamin riboflavin niacin and
so on are all under 50 of what you need
he's not even getting the rda which is
the required dietary allowance of some
of these vitamins and minerals your
total cholesterol is 165 before now it's
225. wow that's a crazy fast increase
but likely due to the huge amount of
saturated fat content that he's
consuming and lack of fiber these
numbers are
absolutely outrageous okay for the first
time we're seeing uric acid elevated so
you're giving yourself hyperuricemia
and the danger of hyperuricemia yeah
stones the results for your liver are
obscene beyond anything i would have
would have thought and only 30 days of
eating nothing but mcdonald's i gained
24 and a half pounds my liver turned to
fat his liver didn't turn to fat had
fatty deposits my body fat percentage
went from 11 to 18
still below the national average of 22
for men and 30 for women i nearly
doubled my risk of coronary heart
disease making myself twice as likely to
have heart failure not only did he
develop high blood pressure his
cholesterol is through the roof he's now
in the overweight if not obese category
with his bmi so his rate definitely went
higher than just double i felt depressed
and exhausted most of the time my mood
swung on a dime and my sex life was
non-existent i craved this food more and
more when i ate it and got massive
headaches when i didn't in my final
blood test many of my body functions
showed signs of improvement but the
doctors were less than optimistic
they probably started returning to
normal because he started feeling
terrible so he changed what he was
ordering remember it's not just that
he's eating mcdonald's it's what he's
ordering at mcdonald's if you eat
milkshakes multiple times a day it's
very different than getting a chicken
sandwich three times a day the calories
are different the macronutrients are
different therefore the effects on your
blood work is going to be different
should people eat fast food
no it certainly needs to be very
restricted and balanced with overall a
healthy diet we're not as doctors
parents to tell people what to do we can
tell them that the risks of eating these
unhealthy foods often is going to put
them at serious risk but at the same
reality we also have to be pragmatic
we're aware of so many things that put a
risk into our patients lives that we
know we can't control everything so
trying to be perfect actually usually
yields to worse outcomes because it
creates problems we weren't expecting or
even destroys the initial goal after a
while because it's unsustainable so
eating fast foods generally unhealthy
eating it for 30 days on its own is a
definite no-no i consumed 30 pounds of
sugar from their food i also took in 12
pounds of fat i hate these treats you
remember when i lost my mind on freaky
eaters oh my god we wanted to show him
the amount of french
fries if this ever growing paradigm is
going to shift it's up to you but if you
decide to keep eating this way go ahead
over time you may find yourself getting
as sick as i did and you may wind up
here or here
i guess the big question is
who do you want to see go first you
or them
i love that he's hoping to put
mcdonald's out of business good luck sir
check out the harsh reality of living at
800 pounds very important video click
here to check that out and again huge
thank you hellofresh for sponsoring this
video as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you